have you ever wondered why certain
presidential candidates or even running
for president they clearly have no
chance and it seems like they are not
only wasting time but also millions of
dollars in the past few election cycles
this has only become more and more true
this election cycle the Democratic side
alone had twenty nine candidates
fighting for one nomination most of
which you have probably never heard of
of course underdogs rise up all the time
in politics but a lot of these people
don't even seem to have the intention to
become president so why in the world are
they even running well starting off one
of the main reasons many hopefuls run is
to build a brand around their name which
allows her voice to become much more
powerful when running for president
presidential candidates have the ability
to draw focus to certain issues that
they may feel passionate about whether
that's health care or the economy when
one candidate is aggressively pushing
for major reform other candidates have
to at least offer something along the
same lines in order to hopefully garner
original Candice demographic of voters
if they were to drop out a perfect
example of this is Andrew Yang and his
notable freedom dividend Andrew yang was
a Democratic presidential candidate who
proposed implementing a form of
universal basic income in order to levy
pressure from Americans facing financial
stress clearly yang didn't have much of
a chance at actually getting the
nomination as he was pulling well under
five percent throughout his entire
campaign despite this he was able to
introduce universal income as an issue
that more likely candidates could
implement in hopes of garnering yanks
voting base for instance Elizabeth
Warren has stated as she's open to the
idea of universal basic income and
Bernie Sanders has stated that his
substitute for universal basic income is
the federal job guarantee as you can see
and Liang was able to build a brand
around him and create a subset of voters
who supported his policies with all of
his main points being universal basic
income as a result even after he dropped
out universal basic income remained
talking point for more likely candidates
so oftentimes
Canada's run for president in the hopes
of focusing
Canada's attention onto a certain issue
moving on another reason candidates
member president is a hopefully escort
cabinet seat or simply gone our
nationwide attention helping them win
their local election more easily it's no
secret that a lot of cabinet seats go to
once presidential opponents for instance
Ben Carson and Rick Perry were both able
to get cab receipts in the Trump
administration before that Hillary
Clinton was able to get a cabinet seat
in the Obama administration after
running for a 2008 election furthermore
even if they don't get a cabinet
position they're able to dominate in
popularity within their own State for
instance Amy Klobuchar didn't really
stand much of a chance as she also
pulled well under five percent most of
her campaign however her bid for the
presidency has no doubt made her a local
sensation within Minnesota which will
probably eight her in many selections to
come but most of these benefits only
applied to career politicians so what
Center for people like Michael Bloomberg
and Ben Carson before he scored a
cabinet seat well aside from political
gain presidential candidates may be
looking for monetary profit running for
president puts candidates on a national
stage where they can sell books signed
television contracts and charged more to
give speeches one of the best examples
of a presidential candidate leveraging
the presidential stage in the profitable
empire is Mike Huckabee Mike Huckabee
started as an Arkansas governor who ran
for the Republican nomination both in
2008 and 2016 though he did win either
nomination I think you'd consider both
campaigns to be successful as he was
able to become a political commentator
after his 2008 campaign and drive even
more traffic to his show Huckabee during
his 2016 campaign similarly would you
rather invite Ted Cruz or John Cornyn to
give a speech at graduation or give an
interview whose book would you rather
read the vast majority of people would
prefer Ted Cruz but in reality Ted Cruz
and John Cornyn are both Texas senators
and John Cornyn and actually been a
senator for several more years then Ted
Cruz really the only difference between
the two is that Ted Cruz remember
President and
john cornyn didn't but this was enough
to guard ted cruz international
publicity and that brings me on to my
final point which is publicity time and
time again
unknown candidates have been able to
create a huge name for themselves by
running for president they may get
obliterated in the primaries or
straight-up closure campaign before the
primaries even take place but they still
get a lot of recognition take beta or
work for example he was a representative
of Texas 16 congressional district and
before he ran for president he had just
lost a Ted Cruz in the Senate was Ted
Cruz's victory aided by his previous
presidential run very possible but
anyway as you can see Boehner didn't
have a very big political career before
running for president however running
for president drew national attention
towards him this is the same case with
Pete Buda Jack he was mostly unknown
clabe ran for president as he was just a
simple mayor but now he's a national
icon when relatively unknown figures are
able to gain so much popularity why not
just run for president to gain
popularity in the end nowadays
presidential campaigns aren't just
focused on gaining nomination and
winning the election in fact you may
have a pretty successful campaign
without directly winning whether a
strong attention towards an issue making
a bid for a cabinet seat gaining money
or just gaining popularity all of these
positive byproducts of running for
president have attracted a new group of
people run for president just like
million third party candidates and
that's why they run for president when
they basically have no chance at winning
if you guys thought this video explained
the benefits of running for president
other than winning the presidency then
measured up alike and consider
subscribing if I see more question just
like this one logically answered but
until then I'm hari I'll see you guys on
the next one